- The kind of reforms and
incremental improvement
that the current system
is capable of delivering
are insufficient,
so some form of radical
reorganization is required.
And I would say that
to focus primarily
on where is power coalescing?
Is it observable?
Are there giant corporations
that are wealthier than nations?
Well, that's an interesting
area to look at.
Are there powerful
energy companies
that are still being
offered subsidies,
that are still being subsidized
when there is an energy crisis?
Is there a military
industrial complex
that's benefiting from war?
Are there pharmaceutical
industries
that are benefiting
from medical crises?
These are all areas that
you might want to locate
as potential problems.
So avert your eyes for a moment
from cultural differences
and focus on where power
and financial cloud
and the ability to organize
is currently centralized
and look at that.
That is the area that we
collectively need to address.
(upbeat music)
- All right, we're not
doing a normal intro today.
I think you might know
this guy, Russell Brand.
Welcome to the Rubin Report
here in Locals in Miami
on your American tour.
- Thanks for having me
on the Rubin Report.
- Pretty good.
We've got our own mugs.
You can have that.
You wanna keep that mug?
- Yes, please.
I'd like you to sign it
and I'll keep it as a memento
of an already lovely occasion,
just arriving here
and meeting everyone.
It's been so lovely.
- You're bouncing all
over the place, man.
It's been a wacky week.
Do you have like a word
that would sum up
what has happened
since you got to America,
the Bill Maher thing,
and then you've done 800
shows and all over the place.
What word would
sum it up for you?
- Vicissitude.
(Dave laughs)
Like it's sort of
like a vacillating,
undulating, shape shifting,
state altering kind of.
It's interesting,
isn't it, mate?
Because where rather
than the vanguard
of the political conversation
would you want to be?
Where else would you want to be?
But the truth is that I don't
do well with antagonism.
I don't do well with it.
I don't care for it much.
I prize serenity very highly.
I don't really
particularly enjoy
being at the center
of incendiary matters
nor do I enjoy being criticized.
Say, if you ask
someone for feedback,
this is what I mean.
"Oh, have you got any feedback?"
Do you know what
I actually mean?
Can you give me a series
of very sincere and
specific compliments now?
(Dave laughs)
That's what I mean,
sincere and specific
compliments.
The way you did
that was brilliant,
thank you.
Then I can sort of
sit and reflect on it
as if like we're
studying something
that's objective and external.
I don't like to feel
attacked in particular,
perhaps nobody does.
Long ago, due to the
nature of a celebrity,
I have broadly elected
to extract myself from
the discourse about me,
deciding as is
suggested in my program,
what other people think of
me is none of my business.
What other people think of
You can do what you want
in your mind, that's yours.
Or you could even
say what you want,
it's none of my business,
it's abstract.
But of course, like on the
level of how I actually feel,
I am, like all of us I'm sure,
a well-intentioned person
and I am optimistic
about human beings
and I'm trying to do something
that I feel is important.
And perhaps I hope
I'm doing it well,
but of course with
no way of knowing.
- Isn't it kind of funny?
Like someone that doesn't
court the controversy
and then you have a moment
like that, Real Time moment...
Which actually, why don't we
just throw to it real quick.
Everyone's seen it
a million times,
we'll throw to it.
(audience laughs)
- It's disingenuous
to claim that the biases that
are exhibited on Fox News
are any different from the
biases exhibited on MSNBC.
(audience applauds)
It's difficult to suggest
that these corporations operate
as anything other
than mouthpieces
for their affiliate owners
in BlackRock and Vanguard.
And unless we start to embrace,
and also mate, like
just spiritually,
if I may use that word
in your great country,
we have to take responsibility
for our own perspective.
I've been on the MSNBC, mate.
It was propaganda, it's
nut crackery in there.
I went on a show
called "Morning Joe."
It was absurd the
way they carried on.
- Good morning Joe.
That's not it.
- I dunno what it was.
It wasn't morning,
there was no one
called Joe there,
no one could concentrate,
they didn't understand the
basic tenets of journalism.
No one was willing to stick
up for genuine American heroes
like Edward Snowden.
And no one was willing to
talk about Julian Assange
and what he suffered trying
to bring real journalism
to the American people.
(audience applauds)
And I think to sit within
the castle of MSNBC
throwing rocks at Fox
News is ludicrous.
Make MSNBC better.
- The moment that you give
me a specific example,
an actual example.
- Okay, I'll give you one-
- Just wait, wait, wait, wait.
- We need just a
specific example-
- How about.
- Calm down, (indistinct)
I'd like to hear a
specific example,
a proof of a specific example
of an MSNBC
correspondent or anchor
being on television saying
something they knew was false
and were saying behind the
scenes to his people...
I'm allowed to go out,
and we know that the
election wasn't stolen
or something equivalent-
- Giving a specific example-
- But I will go on television
and say the opposite.
I will lie.
- [Russell] When's my answer?
- Well, just gimme
the specific example.
- [Russell] I understand
the basic point-
- Gimme a specific example.
- All right.
- I'm with you.
I think it's a false
equivalency, Russell.
- That's your own
biases, plainly.
- It's not about bias.
It's a false equivalency
'cause you don't
actually know anything
about any of these organizations
you're talking about.
You've been on MSNBC
once, big fuckin' deal.
(audience laughs)
(audience applauds)
- My darling, it was
more than enough.
- You don't have a
single actual fact.
- Do you want an example?
Do you want an example?
- Yes.
- The ludicrous
outrageous criticisms
of Joe Rogan around Ivermectin,
which we're deliberately
referring to as a horse medicine
when they know it's
an effective medicine-
- Non-responsive.
- [Bill Maher] That's
not a bad example.
- Rachel Maddow
turning up on the TV
saying if you take this vaccine,
you're not gonna get it,
when it hadn't been clinically
trialed for transmission-
- Nonresponsive.
- You have to listen.
Do you think you
can improve America
by determinedly and
avowedly condemning Fox News
without acknowledging
that you're participating
in the same game?
Did you not just listen
to Bernie Sanders?
Someone who plainly,
legitimately believes
in this country
and believes it's
possible to change
but is bound by corruption,
is bound by the lobbying system.
(audience applauds)
It surely is clear to you, Bill,
as one of the great pundits
and experts and comic voices
that systemic
change is required.
Money has to be taken
out of politics.
We need new political systems
that genuinely represent
ordinary Americans
so that we can overcome
cultural differences.
(audience applauds)
And bickering about
which propagandist
network is the worst
is not gonna save a
single American life
nor improve the life of
a single American child,
not gonna improve America's
standing in the world.
And the world needs
a strong America.
I'll tell you that.
(audience applauds)
So you have an obligation,
a duty not to
condemn these people.
- You weren't being a dick.
I mean, that's the thing.
You were trying to say
something very true,
something that
most of us we know
about media and everything,
but then it gets turned
into like this
destruction of this guy.
And I probably even
feed into some of that
when I covered it on my show.
Like, man, that guy kind
of deserved to get wrecked.
But it wasn't really about him.
You weren't trying
to make it about him,
that was very clear.
- I was astonished that anybody
is willing to go to the mat
for that set of values anymore.
But of course, I
know that people are.
And yeah, I don't like the idea
that I'm being
impolite to a person.
That's not in accordance
with my values.
- But you weren't
really being impolite.
You were being
passionate, right?
Like you weren't rude
to him, I don't think.
I think you were confident
in what you were saying
and it needed to be said.
- Yeah, I feel we can't move
forward with the conversation.
Like it happens in
politics, doesn't it?
When they say, "oh, well
this is only happening,
the last administration
done that"
or "this is because CNN
or Fox News or whoever."
It's like, well,
why don't we focus
on what we are
contributing individually
or if we claim to be
the representative
of some sort of movement, class,
culture, or advocacy group,
perhaps then we can look...
If we claim to speak
on behalf of them
and certainly I
make no such claim,
then we should look after
ourselves and our own conduct.
And because as Gandhi said,
"I find I am such a
sinner in my own life,
I'm not confident when it
comes to judging others."
I try to monitor my own behavior
but I am engaged in punditry,
I am engaged in commentary.
And as I said I suppose
in that conversation,
it's not like I particularly
align with Fox News
as an institution.
In fact, I have a
rather colorful history
with that organization.
- Right, right, right, right.
So when you were
preparing for the show
were they telling you...
Obviously, they do a
pre-interview with you
or you passed that point?
- We kept trying to do it
but I kept not doing it.
I kept not doing
the pre-interview.
- Right, but you knew what the
topics were gonna be, right?
- No, I knew like...
What happened,
they said that that
might come up actually.
I thought that they said we
would talk about the pandemic.
And then I think that they said
that there was a possibility
that the changing nature
of the relationship
between Fox News and
Trump would come up.
And so I suppose it was within
the orbit of that topic,
the contretemp around
the distinctions
between neoliberal
establishment media
and neo-conservative
was discussed.
- Yeah, it was so interesting
because when he was
trying to get you
like, give me the one, right?
Like he was trying to,
"give me one time that
they intentionally lied."
And it's like, man, we
could do this all day.
Very fine people on both sides.
Brett Kavanaugh's
a serial rapist.
The Covington kids are racist.
I mean, I do this on
my show every day.
You went with the Rogan one
and it's like he just
didn't have much after.
- He wanted to, I suppose-
- Does it get to that point
of like it's weird
that anyone defends it?
Is that really what you
think this is about?
I'm starting to
come to that too,
that it's hard to
defend at this point.
- This is where I'm at, Dave.
I'm at why don't
we now acknowledge
that there are different
ways of being a human
and call a kind of truce
and accept that
there are some people
for the sake of simplicity;
that there are progressive
ways of being a human being,
there are traditional ways
of being a human being,
neither of those ways are wrong.
Why don't we allow one another
to express ourselves
how we want to
within the obvious
bounds of consent?
And then perhaps we can
organize different alliances
so that we can organize
around the systems
of centralized power
that will else-wise continue
to dominate and annihilate.
- Do you sense that that's
happening right now?
I mean, me living
here in Florida.
I mean, look, I'm gay, I'm
married, I have two kids.
Like this is the freedom place.
They make it seem like
it's the place of right wing
crazy people and everything.
I'm freaking loved here and I
love it right back, it's wild.
- But no one cares
about being gay
or being married
or having two kids?
- No, it was freaking Halloween.
We took our kids in strollers,
met every neighbor
within 10 square blocks.
Not one weird comment site.
Nobody cares.
That's happening right here,
I think what you're calling for.
But it's not
happening everywhere.
- Do you feel that that
would be able to escalate
through the various expressions
of like every letter
of the LGBTQ+ moniker?
- I mean, I personally
have nothing to do
with that whole thing.
I happen to be gay and I'm
married to a guy and that's it.
I only represent myself
as I think you probably only
represent Russell Brand.
So when they try to
put all these letters-
- If even-
- Right.
(Dave laughs)
- Bits of Russell
Brand I represent
but there are parts of that
guy I want nothing to do with.
- Who's the true representation
of Russell Brand?
- There are so many of us.
"Goodbye Ruby Tuesday,"
who could put a name on you
when you change
with every new day?
- There you go.
Yeah, I don't know that...
Well, let's put it this way,
if there was a trans person
walking around the town,
I don't think they would
be ridiculed or anything.
I think people basically are
just kind of live and let live.
Politics is making us all
kind of nuts at this point.
- Politics and the culture.
And I cannot see it
anymore as inadvertent.
It feels to me that it
must be a requirement
of sustaining the
systems of power
that benefit, for
example, in the pandemic
in the obvious observable and
trackable ways financially
and through the
ability to surveil
and introduce new regulation,
they must benefit
from ongoing conflict.
- So it's a needed
piece of the puzzle-
- It feels to me
like it is, actually.
And so my sense is that
like there cannot be one
homogenized version of...
There cannot be a uni-culture,
there cannot be
a unipolar world,
you cannot have a new hegemonic.
There must be the acceptance
of I would say sort of
compatible, interconnected,
localized systems of governance
that as much freedom,
as much democracy,
as much community
and the systems of...
My sense is, and again
it's just a vague one;
the systems of aggregation
benefit people at
the top of them,
from agriculture through
industrialization
through technology.
Whilst there are obvious
benefits to agriculture
to a population at large,
the most significant gains
are experienced at the
top of those systems.
And the amendments that
are possible are not made,
like industrialization.
And even the sort of like
the so-called white
goods revolution
in this country in the 1950s,
"you are gonna
have plenty of time
with your new dishwasher."
And it's like, do we
have any more time?
Are there different ways of
deploying these sets of tools
or is everything subtly and
unconsciously being used
in the service of
a particular idea
that's oddly centralizing?
- Yeah, Peter Thiel always says,
"they promised us flying cars
and we got 140 characters."
In essence, we've sort
of stopped innovating now
and we're just
doom-scrolling all day long.
Remember back in our day
when the internet stopped?
You'd go to a page and it
would stop at the bottom.
- Oh, yeah.
- Remember that?
And then they got rid of that
so you just scroll forever
and it never stops.
And you're looking for
more, more craziness.
- Yes, it's nihilistic.
- I kind of sense that
you're more libertarian
than anything else.
Even though people
are always like...
The people on the
right are always like,
"he's a lefty but I like him,"
something like that, right?
That's what they
do with Bill Maher.
- I'm a lefty you kinda like.
(Dave laughs)
- There could be
a movie in that.
I think they said that in that.
But I sense you're mostly like,
you're talking about
decentralization,
local communities,
you're talking about
taking power away
and that kind of stuff.
Like you're mostly
just live and let live.
I mean the show is
stay free, right?
- Yes, I suppose when people
talk about libertarianism,
sometimes there's the sort
of is there the suggestion
that we do not have
a duty and obligation
to love and care
for one another?
I suppose I don't feel that
that needs to be mandated
at the end of a gun,
that people can love one
another consensually.
And that we can organize in
various different publics,
we can have the maximum
amount of democracy,
that we can honor the highest
aspects of our nature.
That broadly speaking,
I would respond sympathetically
to a person suffering
if I could see them.
What I'm beginning to feel
is that we have
become disjointed.
There's been an aberration
from the conditions
of our origin.
There's nothing in our evolution
that suggests that we
would be able to live
in societies of
300 million people,
let alone 7 billion people.
Whilst that is
part of the reality
that we are on a rock
in infinite space,
we are also in communities.
And I like that phrase
that I think I heard from
Helena Norberg-Hodge,
"act local, think global."
(Russell chuckles)
So like we can have
as much democracy
in our community as possible,
that we allow people
to organize their communities
however they want to
unless it has a negative
impact on another community
or the individuals
within that community
are not happy with it.
And that we have to accept
that there are many different
ways of being human,
traditional ways, new
and emergent ways,
new roles, new identities allow
people to be who they are,
allow people to have as much
democracy in their schools
as much as the
democracy in their...
Even law and order
ought to be democratic.
In my country, for
example, I heard...
Like I respect very much
people that work in services
'cause I understand
the value of sacrifice
and I have friends that are
working the police force,
thank God.
And like I feel that wouldn't
it be good if the forces,
even law enforcements, a
phrase that's got some...
As a true anarchist libertarian,
that I have some issues with,
because who do you mandate to?
Because the relationship
between sovereignty
and the governed
is traditionally being
you give us taxes,
we won't let you get killed
by bandits or whatever.
But me, personally-
- That would be the basis of it.
(both laugh)
- Yeah, you know those bandits,
they could get you any time.
Give us some of your money
and we'll protect you from it.
But what I feel, Dave,
is that it would be nice
if there were consensual
policing, consensual governance.
You live in the area like
it's sort of localism,
like this phrase.
They are supposed to...
Do you have like particular
phrases and ideas
that have sort of stayed in
the sphere of your awareness
for a long while
and they start to become part
of your personal philosophy?
In my case,
when Gandhi said the point
of Indian independence,
"this is a country
of 70,000 villages,
each one should be
fully independent
trading only where necessary,
running and
governing themselves.
There's no point in us
kicking out the British
then replicating the
very institutions
that they installed."
And it seems that we are
doing this now globally.
Sets of institutionalized power,
whether they're
corporate or state
that don't allow ordinary people
to have very much freedom.
- It's interesting
'cause you're basically
I think selling me,
from an American perspective,
you're selling Federalism.
I mean, the idea that the states
should basically do
everything locally
and that we should have
some structure above that
but it should
probably be way weaker
than this crazy structure
that nobody believes in now,
that is completely ineffective
and probably very authoritarian-
- Oh, if that's the way that
you term it, then certainly-
- Yeah, so Federalism is
the idea that the states...
Basically, as a Floridian,
everything that
goes on with my life
should have to do with Florida
and the laws of Florida.
The US government, the
federal government,
should have basically,
nothing to do with me
except guard the borders
and a couple of make sure
the states aren't at war,
couple other things like that.
- Yeah, leave everyone alone.
I suppose you are-
- It'd be nice for you guys
to have that in the UK, huh?
- I suppose.
Look, the point of the state
is obviously supposed to be
in order to prevent external
attack, military I mean,
or gargantuan corporatism.
One needs a state that can
support the collective will
of the people that elected them.
Now, given that for some time,
and this would
include in my view,
both administrations,
both political parties,
that is so damn near to equal
that a quarrel about
which one is superior,
I would consider
literally a waste of time.
- Even now after COVID?
Because I would agree with you,
I think we're
roughly the same age,
for most of our lives.
But I think something
shifted in COVID
where it's very, very clear
like the Republicans-
- One's better.
- They ain't great, but
like they're much less-
- That's the argument
that Democrats make, Dave.
- Yeah.
- We ain't great but
you get this healthcare.
Or yeah, we ain't great
but we were bearing COVID.
Look, we ain't great, fuck off.
Fuck off then.
This goes-
- But we stayed open here,
it's why I moved here.
That's something.
- Sure, thanks for something.
Thanks.
You know, like I can't get
hard for that conversation.
For like, oh, is
it a bit better-
- [Dave] Great.
And that really was the point
when you were doing
the Fox News, MSNBC-
- That is the point.
- That was the same point.
- It's like let's do better.
Because also like if I always
feel like I'm on the precipice
of the pinker conversation,
of "do you know
that so many people
have been pulled out of poverty
and things are so great now?"
Oh, really?
I must be imagining all
this terrible misery
that I'm seeing everywhere.
All of this despair and
nihilism and desperation,
I must be imagining it.
I must be imagining
a spiritual void
at the very core of our culture.
Because I've just seen,
now that you've told me that
it's never been as good.
You know, I respect
Professor Jordan Peterson.
"Now, throughout history people
are it's been (indistinct)"
But for me, that's
not bold enough.
This is it.
The old idea is dead, the
new ideas must emerge.
It's going to require
new alliances.
new conversations.
If we are unwilling
to have them,
we are going to experience
new forms of authoritarianism
and centralization.
It's already happening.
Both political parties
have been co-opted by the
same corporate forces.
They will behave
in the same way.
Now, I know that in
my understanding,
that you are like down
with Ron DeSantis.
And I don't know
very much about him
except I feel like I
read like about that
and like giving good deal in
the leather the other day,
giving good deals
to the energy folks
and subsidizing things.
Like I don't feel like anybody
that's operating
within that system
is capable of genuinely
representing the
will of the people.
And I'm not saying
that Ron DeSantis is
particularly bad, but no.
And I know he is super
popular here, people love him.
- I would say he's
particularly good here.
- I know.
- He's an aberration.
But I get your broader point
is that if you're
still operating
within the system
that has existed-
- The system itself,
that's actually relevant.
- So I fully accept that.
And also I don't
think any politicians,
whether it's DeSantis
or if you brought back
George Washington,
I don't think they're
gods, they're just people,
so he's operating
within a system.
I would say he's the best that
we can get out of this system
and he's done an awful lot here.
Like we have no crime.
We have basically,
no homeless people.
We stayed open.
We don't mandate...
Like all the stuff
that we're asking for-
- All those things sound great.
But you know that there would
be people from the other...
Like if John Oliver
and he's writing stuff
while watching you now,
they would be saying,
"excuse me," wouldn't they?
And they would in particular
be talking about that library
stuff and the school stuff.
And I watched this
item the other day
about like some
schools they've banned
that two dads of
a penguin thing.
- No, I mean the only thing
they did a thing on it today.
Like this is where
John Oliver, to me,
just like fails miserably.
Like he's making up
most of that stuff.
They banned basically two books.
One of them was about,
what was it called guys?
- [Production
Member] Queer Theory.
- Queer Theory, where
they were literally,
it was gonna teach like third
graders how to give hand jobs.
Literally with what-
- What about that Penguin one?
What about the Penguin one.
- What's that?
- [Production
Member] Gender Queer.
- Gender Queer.
But I don't think the penguin...
You're talking about
the penguin one-
- No, the penguins one's the
two dads raising the chic.
- So they are reviewing
a few things, obviously.
- And also on the John Oliver,
look, come on, you
know what I mean?
I'm just saying like if-
- I don't need to
make you love him-
- If I don't give you
the counter argument
what's the point
in having me here?
- [Dave] Yeah.
- Like what it seemed to
me that they were saying
is that that legislation,
given that it was
drafted by a lawyer,
obviously has like a sort
of a looseness in it.
That means that it
could be applied in ways
that would not be particularly
permissive, excuse me,
or evolved when it
comes to, for example,
being able to have conversations
with even like 17 year old
around sort of sexuality.
And I like feel that
something like...
And again, I'm basing this
on just a YouTube
video with John Oliver.
- Yeah.
- But it seemed to be-
- Just for the record,
it was for K through third
grade, not 17 year olds.
- But he said it
could be applied
because it's not specific
to their language
'cause it would require
parental consent.
Is that like this is
the weather punditry
and I'm just passing out on
all of this research here
'cause I don't know,
but for me, it
would seem that...
And he showed videos of
this sort of testimony
that was leading to
the success of this.
I guess maybe it's in
particular districts
or particular schools.
You'll have to tell
me when you watch it,
you're so much more
qualified in so many ways.
But it appeared to me
to be that that's
the side of things
where I would fall
down the side.
I would want kids that are gay
to know that it's
all right to be gay.
- Right.
Well, of course I
would want that.
But my personal belief
is it has nothing to do
with the public schools.
So that might be where you and I
have a little bit
of a disagreement,
which I'm completely
fine with by the way.
But I mean, think about
it, how old are you?
Do you say how old you are?
Are you-
- Nine.
(Dave laughs)
I'm a nine year old lad.
I'm from Finland.
(both laughing)
Why would you ask me that?
Why would you say that?
I'm feeling so
self-conscious about dying.
What if I die, then
what am I gonna do?
No, I get your point
about public schools.
Well, look-
- I just don't think
a state employee
should be talking to someone
else's kid about sex.
It's as simple as that.
Like that's my basic-
- But obviously the argument,
the counter-argument, Dave,
is that the assumption
of heterosexual...
Like that in a way,
heterosexuality is the norm
is being presented to them.
It's not like you're
talking about sex,
you're talking
about relationships,
because that penguin book
ain't talking about sex,
it's talking about sort
of loving relationships.
So anyway, I'm just...
But I also agree because
when it comes to my children,
I don't want my children-
- Well, that's it.
That's it, right?
- It's funny that I'm commenting
'cause you are a gay man
who's married to a man
and you've got children.
"Sir, I'll tell you a thing
or two about being a gay man."
- Tell me about these penguins.
- Wow, they're gay.
You don't know much about it.
But what I wanna say
is I don't like people telling
me what to do at all, right?
At all on, on anything.
I just wanna be left alone.
And I would like to
form communities on
the basis of consent
and people wanting to
be in that community.
And then through bloody,
tiring, exhausting,
boring democracy,
decide how that
community is evolved
at the maximum level of control.
And when it's handed over,
it's always handed
over consensually
and in a way that's understood.
We are gonna like say,
"oh, I can't be bothered
to work out to run
the sewage plant.
You fuckers do it.
Oh, I can't be bothered."
But when I find
out that the water
is owned by foreign interests
and they're dumping
shit into our rivers,
which is happening
in our country
because the water or all
foreigners have been sold off
when they privatized everything.
I'm not suggesting
renationalize,
community own their assets,
community decide
whether or not they want
sewage dumped in their rivers.
Maximum amount of democracy,
maximum amount of respect
for the environment,
maximum amount of respect,
that's what we aspire to.
And it seems though,
across the aisle.
- You're a
federalist, I love it.
I love it,
you're a federalist-
- Ah, that's what I am.
Maximum amount of democracy-
- I know you don't want labels
but I mean you believe
in local control
and people making
decisions for themselves
with some limited structure.
- Yeah.
And always being
aware of the tendency
to rampant corporatism
because at the moment
that is what's happening.
And when people are
claiming localism,
they're sort of
turning a blind eye
to the way that corporatism
can exploit that localism
if not properly undertaken.
If there's any alliance at all,
it's in order to confront
gargantuan corporate power.
- So as you've been on this-
- And get money out of
politics altogether,
should we offer
that into the mix?
- Yeah.
Isn't it funny that that was
a big thing 20 years ago-
- Where did that go?
- And now it's just gone.
Remember that?
- The politicians
decided, hold on a minute,
let's leave the
money in politics.
- Somebody's gotta
pay for these states.
You ever go out to dinner in DC?
These people are eating well.
- Are they?
- Yeah.
- Of course, they are.
Have you ever been to any of
like the big globalist things?
You ever get...
- No.
- You've never been
invited to any of those?
Sometimes they bring in celebs.
- They might have picked up the-
- But maybe before you
were like fully, you know-
- Yeah, no, never, actually.
Maybe but I can't remember
ever going anywhere
and thinking this
is reprehensible.
- What was the moment that
you got sort of into this,
the politics side of this thing?
I know you're not really
political in a way
but you clearly are
talking about politics.
I mean, you're an
actor and a comic.
Like was that kind
of always in you
or was there like a
moment that it happened?
Did COVID kind of escalate it?
- No.
Actor, comic, that's a
type of a job, isn't it?
Like a comedian, actually for
me is sort of beyond a job,
that's a religion.
- Yeah.
- That's sort of a purpose.
It's a perspective.
Actor is a type of a job for me.
For me, my worldview is
part of my condition,
it's part of where I come from,
it's part of what I believe in.
And becoming an actor,
that's just simply opportunism.
I was doing standup comedy,
I got jobs on the TV
as a result of that,
I then got off the movies,
all of these things.
Oh, these are all
interesting, exciting things.
And by God, were they
exciting and for a while.
But what would we be?
Look, I sometimes think this,
if it didn't exist,
would I invent it?
Like if there was no such
thing as a movie industry,
would I go, "why don't we spend
like a hundred million
dollars telling this story?"
And what we'll do
is we'll get to trailers at
four o'clock in the morning.
I'll stay in there
most of the time,
then I'll pop out for a bit
and I'll like do a
little bit of acting.
No, what I want to do
is communicate truthfully
and connect people.
If anything,
it's like a kind of secular
and inclusive evangelism
that's deeply devout and
accepting of the different ways
that people might find God.
That each of us are gonna
have our own journey to God.
That doesn't mean
that people might not be
part of a religious community
or indeed a global faith,
but that if we do not have
a connection to something
that I would call
sublime or divine,
that we are likely to
become lost in materialism,
individualism, nihilism,
and progressivism.
And by progressivism I don't
mean cultural progressivism,
the idea that human
beings are on this journey
to better and better stuff.
And that doesn't
seem to be happening
other than I would say
through the false markers
of medicine and technology.
And although they are
marvelous, great miracles.
- Is that what you're up
to more than anything else?
That we're just like in this
lack of truth right now?
And even to bring it back
to the Real Time moment,
like you were trying
to say something true
in a culture war where
nothing is true, right?
Like you do your show every day,
you talk about politics
and it's like a lot of it is
just debunking bullshit, right?
Like the people that
just shovel all day long.
- Yes, that is what
I'm trying to do.
What I feel like, mate,
is that I'm limited in my
understanding of most things.
In fact, the sum total of all
human knowledge is negligible
compared to the
vast limitlessness
of all potential realities.
So there has to be a
kind of blunt pragmatism
to the way that we organize
culture and society.
And the only reference
that I can access
is how did we evolve?
Did we evolve to live
in giant communities?
I can see that there are ways
where living, like
having broad alliances
would be hugely beneficial.
I can see that there are ways
where the miracles of technology
in medicine and science
are hugely, hugely applicable.
Obviously, of course,
I live in the world
but it seems that there
is an invisible ideology
that doesn't declare and
state itself explicitly.
And all of the even
apparent cultural arguments
happen to take place
within its framework.
And what I would call
it is commodification,
consumerism, late
capitalism, corporatism,
global corporatism,
neoliberalism
that this ideology isn't
being openly discussed
and it's at its
Nadia, it's dying.
It's already dead.
It died in 2008
and now we've got something
bizarre and monstrous.
- So we have like a Frankenstein
trying to keep it
together or something
while they were rearranging
chairs on the Titanic
as it's sinking.
Something like that?
- Yes, that's what I feel like.
Yes, that's what I feel like.
And I feel like
if it is not succinctly
and explicitly addressed,
we are going to experience
new types of authoritarianism
that frame themselves in, or
albeit apparently novel ways.
That benefit hugely from
arguing about the sort of stuff,
like even the stuff
about like the public
schools or whatever,
when plainly like that,
if you said, oh, I wanna
raise my kids in this way,
I'd go, oh, okay.
And I would assume that you
would be the same with me.
Like who cares?
As long as it's
not sort of abuse.
There seems to be some universal
ideas that we understand.
- When you're traveling,
do you see places that
it's working better
than other places?
I mean, now you've been
a couple days in Florida,
but you were just in Cali
where it's obviously
way different-
- I did a standup
show in Clearwater.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- And I really liked it.
And what I do recognize, yes.
And I do recognize that
there's a sort of a deep sense
of sort of like pride here
and that's obviously
somewhat due to the stance
that Florida took
during the lockdown,
that anti-authoritarianism
is being expressed.
Like the governor
is the anti-government
figure in your state.
And you know, why not?
I'm not pessimistic about human
beings, generally speaking,
but I would always just look
at where is the
funding coming from?
What's the ultimate intention?
What kind of alliance?
I would just ask
the same questions
that I would ask of anybody.
Is it as democratic as possible?
And I'm like the "it's better
than" I would always reject
from both sides, as we've said.
That's what I was
sort of rejecting
on the tele program
the other day.
And I don't know Ron DeSantis,
for all I know,
he could be Jesus.
But sort of like-
- I'm pretty sure
he is not Jesus,
but maybe I can get you
guys to sit down for coffee.
How about that?
- Yeah, God, absolutely.
You know, I'd like that.
I'd like that.
What I do accept, Dave,
is that I feel that we want
the maximum amount of authority
in our own lives.
Maximum personal authority
and autonomy, excuse me.
And the maximum
amount of democracy.
And like I told you at the
beginning of this conversation,
I don't really like controversy.
And I don't think that
any of that stuff's even
particularly complicated.
I'm just sort of inviting people
that identify on the right
to be as discerning as
I would invite people
that identify on
the left to be like.
Are we definitely operating
on behalf of ordinary people?
Totally inclusive,
non-judgmental,
completely loving,
not secretly operating
on behalf of economic
interests in some, you know-
- Is one of those directions
easier than the other?
Like right now, obviously
people on the right dig you.
And that's I think probably
a little weird for you
in some respects, right?
Like people that maybe
a couple years ago
you thought, ah, these weren't
my people, but they're.
That's what I found.
I was a lefty my whole life.
And then suddenly I
started saying a few things
about freedom,
kind of what you're
preaching here
in a probably more
simplistic way.
The next thing I knew,
all these people that I
thought were the bad guys
were like, Hey, you
wanna have dinner?
Let's see what's what.
- But what I will say-
- I like how you
switch mugs like that.
(Russell laughs)
What was in there?
I had no idea what's in there.
- And also it's gone
from blue to red.
- Yeah.
Oh, wow.
- Right off our point in
the conversation, huh?
Because in a way,
it doesn't matter.
They're both basically the same-
- How very effective, wow.
- There's still statistics on
where the funding comes from,
on the number of
people in Congress
that own stocks and shares
in like energy companies
or the military
industrial complex.
It's just basically the same.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- It's just basically the same.
So that's just sort
of my position.
Certainly, I've
found that people
identify as being sort of
conservative or Republican
or whoever have been very
open to this conversation.
And look, it's clear to
me and a matter of record
that about 30, 40 years ago,
or maybe even earlier than that,
the liberal establishment
became co-opted
by the same financial interests
that have traditionally
been associated
with right wing politics.
If you look at the conditions
that led to the war in Iraq
and the kind of relationships
and the kind of restructuring
that took place in that country,
and the catastrophe that
happened around that war,
that was Janie and Bush.
And now look at what's
happening elsewhere.
And there are sort of,
I would say, comparable
conversations that
could take place.
And it's pretty clear
where like the sort of Clinton
Foundation gets money from
and the way that they advocate
for particular things.
So what I feel like is that
the solution will not come
from within that system.
I don't want to glory it by
reveling in the differences
because actually
where I am from,
is a normal, modest, blue
collar working class background
in Essex, England.
And when I see people demonized
on the basis of their
class or their culture,
whether they are in the
dominant cultural group
sexually or racially
or culturally,
or a smaller cultural
group by those markers,
if economically we are
attacking people...
If we're attacking a class
that is economically
dispossessed,
then I feel like, oh, I
see what's happening now.
I see what's happening.
I see why people are angry.
I see why people feel that
they're being spoken down to,
they are being spoken down to.
And I suppose, Dave,
that that's the thing that I
felt wasn't being addressed
and isn't being addressed.
That the blame is being put on
people that aren't empowered.
And also that
there's an escalation
of the kind of
accusations around, God,
what do I wanna say?
Perjuring people's beliefs.
Oh, those people
are just racist.
Those people are
this, are just that.
And I'm actually generally
quite optimistic about people
and think that
people will get along
if you leave them alone
and if you don't impecuniate
them and impoverish them.
- Do you think a
whole bunch of people
are just gonna kind of
check out of the system?
Because I think a lot of people
intuitively get
what you're saying
and they really do want to
live and let live thing.
I think there really
is a feeling of that
in America right now.
That the whole system is so
screwed up, it's so wacky,
it's not in it for anyone
except the few that control it.
I think a lot of people
are just gonna be like,
all right, I'm
just checking out,
I'm deleting the accounts,
I'm figuring out how
to get off the grid
and just really just
kind of disappearing.
I think it's probably
happening as we speak.
- I wonder about that movement.
I wonder about sort of
a second kind of
declaration of independence.
Like what would happen
if people did that?
Our community,
we are no longer associating
with the super structure.
We want our own new confederacy.
- Have you heard
of that in America?
They're talking about it now.
Texas, there's some congressmen
that put forward a bill
to have a succession
and just get out of the union
and that maybe some of the
red states could move out,
something like that.
It seems like we're united,
but what are we united by?
It's hard to figure out-
- I wonder.
Yeah, I guess that's
a conversation that
needs to carry on.
It needn't be presented
as adversarial-
- Right, that's the thing.
It comes off as adversarial,
but it shouldn't.
- In our country, which is
obviously an absurd term
because a country is a concept.
What is it really?
A flag, a set of beliefs
of a group of people?
If it isn't benefiting those
people, what is it doing?
- That land mass
across the pond-
- You see that thing?
Do you know this
language you're using?
Like the devolution
was a big conversation
like a few years ago.
And Scottish
independence is discussed
and Wales has an assembly.
And obviously, because of
colonization and imperialism era
in the north of that country,
and because Britain is an
imperial and colonial power,
historically, these
conversations have been ongoing.
And I feel like if
these institutions
do not exist for the
benefit of the people
that they claim to serve,
what is it that they are doing?
And I think that's
the type of inquiry
that I don't claim
to have the answer to
or the conclusions to,
but I feel that that
ought be the investigation
that takes place.
And it oughtn't be disingenuous
and it oughtn't be a sort of
sly way of masking corporatism
or allowing people to
avoid this or evade that
or benefit from this.
The term that keeps occurring
to me as such is "good faith."
Let's have good
faith conversations.
Oh look, we're different
from one another.
How do you wanna organize this?
How do you think the people
best can behave collegiately?
What's the sort of critical mass
before this gets a
little complicated?
Because the tendency appears
to be economically led,
globalism currently
becoming instituted
in an attempt to create
a unipolar hedge money
through various means
and an inability to accept
that there are a
variety of cultures
that sort of are
independently vying
for their right to exist.
- You ever worry we're in
that dystopian future already?
Like we're too deep in it
to the point where we don't
even know we're in it exactly.
You know, Skynet's
basically been turned on,
the machine is operating
and we're kind of
all in the matrix.
We have these little glimmers.
I kind of think it's why your
clip on Real Time took off.
It was like a little
glimmer of truth
amongst all of the lies.
And we see it and then we
all get lost in the BS again.
And then you wait
for another glimmer,
but you sort of just never
get out of the slumber.
Something like that.
- Yeah, I do feel that.
But I also deeply believe in
the possibility of awakening
and what I haven't
mentioned yet,
because I guess, I
tend to communicate
in accordance with the
context that I find myself in,
is that most of
what I believe in
is undergirded by
spiritual beliefs
rather than political ones.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- I don't actually...
You know, all I know politically
is just sort of just
a conversational
layman's knowledge.
Like you know what I mean?
I've not been through
higher education,
I've not been to university,
I don't claim to know
any more than anybody that's
just watching this now.
- But that's why your
politics is interesting
because it doesn't
come from politics,
it's obviously coming
from something else.
That's why I think it's hitting.
- It comes from a sense of
like that as human beings,
we know that we need
meaning and purpose.
We know that we have this
sort of yearning for freedom,
freedom of expression, freedom
to be who we really are.
We also know that there are
a myriad ways of being human.
And that there seems to be
some scarce remembered time
where we could live differently.
There seems to be an awareness
that we are not at the apex,
but we are at the
end of something.
That this could go either way.
That we could yield to more
centralizing authoritarianism
or we could look at
different models.
That there may be
information in the past,
deep, deep in the past, arcane,
anthropological information.
There may be even in the
genius of Thomas Paine
and your founding
fathers and all that,
stuff that's of real value.
But certainly,
there needs to be some
new principles enacted.
And I think that even to move
forward into that territory,
we might have to
offer one another
the grace of a certain
amount of discordance.
- So what do you do if a
certain amount of people
don't want to offer that grace?
Because again, I'm with you
and I think a lot of people
watching this are with you-
- Violent war, Dave.
(both laugh)
- You have to take
camps, I assume, right?
No, but what do you do if
you sit down with the...
You know, if Florida was like,
"Hey, we've just
kind of had enough.
No offense, we're just
gonna do our thing
and take care of our people.
It's gonna be very
pleasant here.
Let everybody live as
free as they want."
But if the other guys
just keep saying,
"no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
we still want some of that.
We want some of the cash,
we want some of the
goodness, we want..."
What do you do then?
- I suppose then
Florida would have to-
- Because I think a lot of
people are thinking about it.
- I think the ordinary
people of each of the states
would have to...
It has been long argued,
typically, I would have
to say from the left,
that the ordinary
people of the world
have more in common
with one another
than they have with
the elites that govern.
And that this has the potential
of being communicated now
through the miracles that
we are currently enjoying.
In his book, The
Revolt of the Public,
Martin Gurri, the
former CIA analyst
who you should have on your
show if you haven't already.
- No, no I haven't.
- Yeah, he's good man.
He says that just
the technology, the
medium in a Malcolm...
What am I trying to say?
Malcolm McLeod-
- The medium is the message.
- The message.
Yeah, yeah.
Like that what we
are experiencing now
is the ability to communicate,
to discern in new ways that
power is organizing differently.
That you can't centralize
and control in the same way.
So new forms of
authoritarianism are emerging.
And we've already seen
through Napster and the
Arab Spring and Occupy,
the potential for organization
almost spontaneously.
That I would say that
these are the conversations
I'm having now.
And the reason that
I'm having them
is that if like why even...
You could even reject
the term Florida,
you could reject
the term New York.
You could decide how
like I would say,
the maximum amount of democracy
needs to be as
local as possible,
as local as possible,
as little centralized
authority as possible.
But there obviously needs to
be a degree of organization.
I would say, well, if the price
of people of Florida
being left alone
is the people of California
being left alone,
if you want to use those
geographical, preexisting states
and that kind of terminology-
- I'm just trying to bring us
down to something on earth.
I got what you're doing at
the meta physical level.
Yeah, yeah.
- As much democracy as possible.
As much democracy as
possible, I suppose.
And again, this sort of
is not going to be
immediately perfect,
but which social system ever
has arrived fully formed?
And also, we are not aiming
entirely for perfection,
we are aiming for improvement.
And the kind of reforms
and incremental improvement
that the current system
is capable of delivering
are insufficient.
So some form of radical
reorganization is required.
And I would say that
to focus primarily on
where is power coalescing?
Is it observable?
Are there giant corporations
that are wealthier than nations?
Well, that's an interesting
area to look at.
Are there powerful
energy companies
that are still being
offered subsidies,
that are still being subsidized
when there is an energy crisis?
Is there a military
industrial complex
that's benefiting from war?
Are there pharmaceutical
industries
that are benefiting from
medical crisis, right?
These are all areas
that you might want to
locate as potential problems.
So avert your eyes for a moment
from cultural differences
and focus on where power
and financial cloud
and the ability to organize
is currently centralized,
and look at that.
That is the area that we
collectively need to address.
- This isn't the most
comfortable question,
but do you ever get nervous
that you're hitting
close to something?
- Oh, no.
- And do you get nervous
about just your life?
Like you don't have to do this,
you can check out and disappear
and you can meditate
and jump in the ice bath
and do all the stuff that
you wanna do forever,
but you're hitting
close to something
and that comes with risks.
However you wanna-
- Don't you think...
Are we are not all
doing the same thing?
You are not doing it?
- No, I do think about that-
- We are doing it.
- Yeah, we are doing it.
- So you are in there as well.
- Yeah.
And I do think about it
and I think about it
now more than ever
because now I have
two young kids
where before, it was
just me, one guy.
Now I've got other issues,
other people to take care of.
Or do you just
not think about it
because you're just
doing it and that's it?
- Well, sometimes I think
about stuff like that,
but I really believe
in some things.
I really-
- No, I know you can't stop,
but that's what my
answer is, I can't stop-
- I'm quite flawed
and also you know, I can
be pretty selfish as well.
You know what I mean?
I'm personally in recovery.
That's what I am really,
is a person in recovery.
So I'm aware of my
frailties, I'm aware of that.
And in a way, isn't it that...
Yeah, I'm trying not to
augment self-fetishization
because I generate
enough of that in house.
Like I find it pretty easy
to get sort of
excited about myself,
so I try to focus on, can you
be of any use to other people?
And I'm aware looking
at this conversation,
with people like, "no, Ron
DeSantis is absolutely amazing."
And like, maybe he
is, I don't know.
You live in Florida, you
are friends with him,
you know more than me.
All I'm asking is what
are the interests?
Are people benefiting?
And the answer, like when I
did that show in Clearwater,
people were happy, man.
They were happy.
But I'd told some
terrific jokes,
so I've gotta take some
of the credit for that.
- Yeah.
How many terrific jokes you got?
- Well, actually,
ones that are deliverable
conversationally, probably zero.
(Dave laughs)
Like my jokes are long, long,
but there's a laugh
every 20 seconds.
It's good gear.
You would have a good
time, you and your husband.
Maybe don't bring the kids,
but like it would-
- They don't speak English
yet, we'll be all right.
- No way.
- Well, they don't
speak anything-
- Oh, they're babies.
- They're babies, yeah.
(Russell laughs)
- I thought that he was
raising them to speak Polish-
- Yeah, they only speak Polish-
- This is a good
move, I like it.
Polish speaking
children, why not?
- Doing standup.
Is that you at your best?
- It's a relief.
- Is that you as you're
just like pure joy?
- Because that's
what I've always said
is that people can see...
It's easy, like look,
I know like say for the thing
we've been to Bill Maher,
they'll extract a bit of it.
They'll go,
"oh, Russell Brand histrionic
breakdown. (mumbles)"
And they won't go, but
look, he spoke about Bernie.
It's like, look, Bernie
Sanders is trying his best.
He's talking about
centralized authority.
I know you're not down
with Bernie Sanders,
but like I think
he's personally-
- You were, I think,
explaining Bernie's positions
better than Bernie.
That was the funny thing,
because when they asked...
When Bill asked him about
equity and equality,
he completely had no answer-
- That infuriated
you, didn't it?
- Yeah.
- You hate people not
to know the difference
between equity and inequality.
- The basic shit.
Like how do you say
to the socialist,
do you know the
difference between
socialism and capitalism?
And he had no idea.
Like that in essence
was what happened.
But you tried to kind of help
him a little bit in a way.
You were a better communicator
of his ideas, I think,
than he is.
Which is-
- My hope is that Bernie Sanders
is a person that is
genuinely interested
in decentralizing power
and attacking corporatism
and standing up for
ordinary Americans,
because if that isn't
what you are doing,
then there isn't anything
else to do in politics.
There isn't any
other job in politics
except representing the
interests of ordinary people.
Service, love, devotion.
Oh no, financial institutions
have got too much power.
Oh no, there's too
much lobbying money.
Oh no, this two pi
system isn't working.
If you're not doing that...
So I have to approach
people with good faith.
So I guess I should say,
yeah, let's approach Ron
DeSantis and Bernie Sanders
and Donald Trump and
Elizabeth Warren.
Let's look at them.
Let's assume they're
doing their best
and let's see what
the results are.
(both laugh)
If the results are,
those people are
individually very wealthy
and ordinary people are
homeless and destitute-
- They all get very rich.
- Oh no. (laughs)
- Isn't that weird?
They all get very
rich while doing this.
- Isn't it a sweet coincidence.
- It's gone bizarre.
How did Obama get...
He's got like a
$30 million house
in Martha's Vineyard
on the water.
Isn't that bizarre?
- It's unfortunate
that people tend to end
up accumulating money,
but I'm being paid also.
- Yeah.
- I'm being paid.
But also, I don't run
a political party.
- You don't just send the-
- I don't think
there should be any.
- You don't just
send back the cash?
You keep that, you keep that.
I'm just happy to sit
in front of the sign
and chat with people.
- You don't feel...
I don't sense you feel
any guilt about that.
A lot of people feel
guilt about their success.
And you care about other people
but I don't sense
you're guilty in a way
that like a lot of the lefties
of Hollywood would be like,
oh, on one hand they'll
be super wealthy
and live in the nicest
house in Bel Air.
And then on the other hand
they'll pretend that
they're guilty about it
when it clearly isn't
lined up with their life.
- Well, sometimes I do feel
a bit guilty, actually.
- Do you?
- A little bit.
I mean, I wish that everybody
lived really, really well,
but as I say, I come from
a pretty normal background
and for a while I
was a drug addict
and I've lived on welfare
for a significant
portion of my life,
only a few years when
I was signing on,
that's what you
call it in England.
And so I do a bit think,
"oh God, is this right?"
But then 'cause also it's
for me, the grandiosity,
"but I earned this on merit."
I do recognize
that there are certain
revenue generating skill sets
in the culture that
rewards, for example,
comedy or football
or legal expertise.
I recognize how
these things happen.
And I also don't think
that moderate affluence
is the real problem,
I think it's
corporate gigantism.
So I try not to, again, be
too self-flagellating about it
'cause that's a form
of vanity as well.
- Right.
And for as much as you
may have some cool stuff
and do your thing, it's like-
- I've got this
now, this jumper-
- You have a lovely sweater.
And that necklace must have
been, I can only imagine.
- I've had it ages.
(both laugh)
I've had this ages.
- But the point is that
your level of wealth
is not the wealth that
you're talking about
that's pulling the
strings of the machine
and all that kind of stuff-
- If I had to set a cap, it
would be the amount I have-
- It would be the exact
amount, you're right there.
You're right at the precipice
of being the bad guy.
- After that there's gotta
be some real redistribution.
- Yeah.
- Do you find that
all the basic problems
of everything we're
talking about here,
whether you're back
home in the UK or here,
that it basically is the same?
That the way we all
talk about the problems
now has become global?
- It feels like
there's some variety.
What I wonder is,
I ask myself, would I be happier
if I lived a life
of complete service?
Would I be happier?
Is it working for me?
Are the systems working,
the systems of
personal gratification?
I've improved a lot.
I don't live how I used to live.
That's the question
that I ask of myself is,
do things seem different
in different places?
I suppose so,
but there does also seem
to be a general sense
that is quite global.
And I don't know what it's
like in Pakistan or Luxembourg,
but like in the places
that I go to and know,
I feel like there is a hunger
and appetite and unease,
a sense of atrophy.
And most cultures talk
about ages and epochs
and identifiable
periods and trends.
And of course, perhaps there's
even an narcissism to that
because all of us are going
to experience Armageddon,
we are all going to die.
And I do query sometimes, Dave,
whether it matters-
- Even in Florida?
I think we'll be okay
here from the death thing-
- Especially in Florida,
looking at some of
the demographic.
Like I feel that perhaps
there's a kind of vanity to it,
does it matter if everyone
dies simultaneously or not
if the planet is going
to ultimately expire?
But I do believe in the
sanctity of human life,
I do believe in the
unique beauty of our kind,
of our species and
I do believe in God.
And I do believe that we're here
to realize something
valuable and beautiful
and that we should
be aspirational
in our relationships
with one another.
And for me, as we were
discussing earlier today,
if it isn't based in action,
like if your experience of
love and devotion in the divine
doesn't have some
expression in your behavior,
then it's fantasy.
- Do you have parts of your life
that you haven't kind
of put together yet?
- Yeah, the whole thing really.
I'm still trying to
just work it all out.
I'm still trying
to work it all out.
I've recognized that
when I'm sort of...
I'm quite tired today,
I'm a bit worn out and it's
almost a little bit tearful,
but like I recognize that I
have a facility for language
that could perhaps mask the fact
that I acknowledge that I don't
really know what I'm doing.
I'm just asking some questions.
I don't actually think
that anyone else knows
what they're doing either.
That's what I've always thought
when like I'm dealing with
sort of political demagogues,
like sort of Boris
Johnson or anybody,
no one knows.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- What do you know?
What does anybody know?
I know like there are people
that are expert plumbers
and expert in construction
and medicine and all of that,
and that there are different
fields of expertise.
But all of this for me leads
to the smallest possible model.
Smallest possible
business model.
democratic models,
most ability to organize
your own life possible.
Not like that life
becomes abstract
and your role is to sort
of stare at a screen
and participate only
through consuming.
So you don't have any role
other than the abstract
expressions of your own outrage.
- Yeah.
The famous quote,
by Solzhenitsyn,
"and all that we have to..."
In essence, I'm gonna
slightly butcher it,
but we just have-
- He went through
worse in them Gulags.
- Those Gulags were rough.
But basically he said,
all we have to do to end this
is stop participating
in the lie.
And it seems like
everyone basically
is participating in the
lie, even accidentally.
And I mean that for us, guys
that are responding to stuff
because it's out there and
we're trying to make sense of it
for people or for ourselves,
and yet we still have
to participate in a game
that's pretty dirty.
- Well, that's what
I have been saying
in these conversations,
explicitly, in the
case with Joe Rogan.
And now I will say to you,
perhaps it isn't enough
for us to engage only in
punditry or even advocacy.
Perhaps it has to become,
alright then let's
try and build.
Well, I think that there
should be communities
of like subgroups of around,
I don't know, is it
a hundred people?
That's what chimpanzees
seem to do well with.
What that 2% of DNAs
gotta afford us something.
Maybe we can run slightly
larger communities.
What are the general principles?
What is the amount of
power you want to yield?
How many ways are there
of organizing this?
How much can we leave
one another alone?
Perhaps we do need to be
involved in a new confederacy-
- That's why I built this thing.
That's why I built this thing.
I mean I built this company,
we merged with Rumble
to do exactly this
at the digital level.
I haven't built my own-
- It'd be good if you
just meant this sign-
- I meant this sign.
I put this together,
I built this.
It's pretty nice, right?
It's sturdy.
Come on, that's a sturdy sign.
- Very satisfying,
it's brilliant.
I really like it, well done.
I mean, but also it's a-
- But that is what
you mean, right?
Like that we have
to build new things.
You don't just mean
physical communities,
you mean like we have to rebuild
sort of everything, right?
- Yes.
- That's a lot of work.
- I know,
but like maybe if we were all
doing just our own little bit
then it's sort of
manageable, isn't it?
I mean, again, that's another
thing I get from recovery.
The idea that we're all a
bit mental and a bit broken,
but not at the same time.
And it's nice to be able
to reach out to someone
and say I'm having a bit of a...
Like we can connect not at
the point of our posturing,
but at the point of
our vulnerability.
So actually like, I don't know.
I don't know what to do.
What do you think?
It seems you're...
I had any experience once
where I stopped to help a
person who had had an accident.
It wasn't a serious accident.
She'd only banged her head
a bit in a car in the UK
and I was sort of helping,
like 'cause I stopped
because it's a human duty
and lots of other
people stopped too.
And like it was an
interesting community
that formed around
that accident.
And an off duty paramedic
ultimately arrived at the scene.
And I saw that in that instance,
that is the person that
you want in authority.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- But moments later,
someone else might be required
to be in a position
of authority.
So having intransigent
systems of power
that are based on the assumption
that human beings need to
be marshaled compliantly
into community or
into behaving well,
I am at odds with.
And you say libertarianism
and as I understand that
that means individual freedom
and the most freedom
as an individual.
Whether that's the freedom
to express your sexual
identity consensually,
or the freedom to express
whatever aspect of
yourself that is.
And what I understand
of anarchism,
it's about the maximum
amount of democracy
and the least amount of
dominion by organization
happening at the
level of community.
And the people that I admire,
women like Helena Norberg-Hodge
for years has been
advocating for,
"you should eat food
that's grown where you are
and people should support
local farming enterprises."
And Vandana Shiva who,
"do not let industrialized
agriculture take over the wall."
Like these voices
ought to be integrated,
incorporated, amplified.
And these terms
of left and right,
I reckon we've gotta
let go of them.
I mean, I know that's sort
of part of your narrative,
your story, your life.
Is that you've transitioned
from liberal to you know...
And I don't feel like I'm
saying anything different
than I was saying
when I was a kid
of like, I'm anti-institution
and establishment corruption.
And like these were the
things I was saying.
I think last time I was here
people thought I was
like a Marxist communist,
now I'm a right-wing
conspiracy theorist,
I'm saying the same thing.
- It's kind of fun
to keep people on their
toes though, right?
Like in its own way,
even though I don't think you're
doing it by design, right?
- Next time I'll come
back as a vampire.
I'm a vampire now.
I'm Pinocchio.
- Yeah.
Then you'll have a serious
political movement behind you,
"the vampires."
I could see that.
What else is on your mind that
you're not doing publicly?
- Nothing.
- Is it like you're just
like a canvas out there
and it's just kind of-
- No, like I live...
Like look, the focus of my
life is my wife and my children
and my meditation and my
recovery and Brazilian jiu-jitsu
and just trying to hold together
the ability to do what you
know, like our jobs now
of like broadcasting five
days a week on Rumble
and creating that content
and trying to manage
these complex arguments
that can easily become
divisive in sundry.
- Yeah, it ain't easy.
- It ain't easy, Dave.
Mate, is it an hour yet?
Because I feel like I really
need to wee quite bad.
- Yeah, you gotta wee?
I think a wee moment-
- Ain't that been an hour?
- How long has this been
since we started talking?
- Yeah, it's been
about an hour, I think.
- [Production Member] An hour.
- Okay, can I stop talking
'cause I'm not so tired-
- I've never ended an interview
with someone having
to go to the bathroom,
but I feel that that's
appropriate for this.
- Is it al right?
- Yeah.
Is there anything else
you wanna talk about
in terms of your bodily-
- I've got a standup
show on Locals.
- Bodily functions.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I meant just
the personal side,
is there anything else?
- No, my bodily functions
are also quite good.
A general sense of
weariness and fatigue,
but also optimism
about your country
and the potential
of conversations
such as the ones we are having
to lead to new forms of alliance
and an optimistic approach
to politics and culture.
- Can I just say one thing
before I let you pee and
then I promise you can-
- What if I just go?
I mean ,just the-
- I guess you could do
that but it would be-
- Just sort of relax.
- But I promise you
it's a nice thing.
Which is that, for me,
doing this whole thing
and talking about
politics the way I do
and the culture wars
and all of this stuff
and that I somehow decided
to create a company
that then merged with
the other company.
And that one of the guys
on the shortlist of people
that I think is making
sense in the world
is sitting in the room with me
doing this right
now and all that.
Like that's the thing,
that's the other thing.
That's the subtext between
the other political thing.
You're giving me that look
that I know means you got it
so I think we're good.
- You're lovely, Dave.
Thank you.
- Right.
If you're looking for
more uncensored opinions
from today's thought leaders,
check out our media playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a wide variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlist all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.